[Music]
foreign
all right so hillel fooled why are you
up at
6 45 a.m listen michael matthias asks me
to get up
and get up that's it tells me to show up
and show up there's no questions asked
here man what are we going to tell you
on that dog man
how am i going to say no to that dog all
right all right okay okay hello
you're in like 50 places at once i i
seriously can't keep up
even if i wanted to i can't keep up how
do you do it
today is my day is that way yeah well
yeah today is my day but i was referring
to what's in the cup a lot of caffeine
no but um
i mean listen it's become it's become
somewhat of a cliche to give this answer
and so you'll forgive me in advance for
the cliche
um but it's it's really the truth and
you know i know that it's maybe a cliche
for other people for me it's it's been
my career
and the answer to that question is
passion uh it's it's genuine authentic
passion for for what i do
uh loving every second of it i don't
obviously view it as work and so
i wake up at 4 00 am to catch up on tech
news it's because well how can i not
wake up at 4am to catch up on tech news
um and so you know when i interview
entrepreneurs and when i'm
working with startups that's what i love
doing so yeah
just trying to you know maximize my time
okay
fine but you're excited about tech
you're excited about entrepreneurship
but
but you know after i don't know how many
years you've been doing this how do you
not develop some sort of cynicism
and another startup raised another 20
million dollars in the cyberspace and
another health tech
i mean i i i get the passion i'm
passionate myself but
how do i maintain this passion 10 20
years down the line
i've been doing this for over 10 years
um i i don't think
cynicism and passion are mutually
exclusive i can be cynical and when i
eat when someone calls me and says hey i
have an idea for a startup that's gonna
be the next facebook you know i
i get pretty cynical and then my passion
kicks in of explaining to them why an
idea for a startup is
is virtually worthless um and that
facebook didn't have an idea twitter
didn't have an idea
none of these companies had any ideas
they had execution um and so
you know i think yeah i think i am i am
cynical because i see a lot of garbage
and a lot of
you know ridiculous ideas um
but you know you can be cynical and
passionate at the same time
okay so so tell me what you you can't be
passionate about
everything about all tech and all
entrepreneurship so what really gets you
excited throughout your throughout the
endless number of people that you're
meeting
i think um much like the business
sector as a whole i don't think
technology is the focus here in other
words it's not the technology that gets
me excited
yeah i love i love technology but what
gets me excited is meeting these
entrepreneurs
who literally they fire in their eyes
and you know
more often than not looking to change
the world by means of technology but
the technology is not the center of
anything i don't think any company
today's well i'm not going to say
today's economy because today doesn't
there is no economy but i mean two
months
three months ago economy um i don't
think any company
won because of the technology right the
technology is not
it's not the course not the center of it
all it's the execution you know it's
marketing is a big part of it um but i
think
both an idea and technology you know raw
technology are
not not worthless because they're
they're the means to the end of the
vehicle but that's
that's all they are they're the vehicle
so just so just for a bit of context you
advise dozens of startups you work with
the biggest companies in the world
uh you meet dozens of people a day and
you
record and you and you take a recording
of it on your
405 vlog episodes on youtube where each
of them
is incredible um what i mean
after after 10 years give me give me
some of your two cents of
of what do you what some of the biggest
mistakes and some of the biggest
successes that you see
over and over again and if you were to
create something what what are the key
takeaways that you would take from this
time
okay so it is important to give a
disclaimer first of all i'm you know
it's easy for me to talk as the guy who
stands on the sidelines i'm you know i'm
not risking millions of dollars in years
of my life building companies
you know so i and again and i have built
companies and i haven't built any
billion dollar companies so
disclaimer like i'm just giving my
opinion and you know
anybody's more than welcome to ask the
following question what has this guy
done in his life and the answer is
nothing so
well it's good enough for inc and the
jerusalem post so it'll be good enough
for me too
all right so um well listen i think that
mistake number one that i see is uh the
glorification
of entrepreneurship people you know they
read on techcrunch that this company
raised 300 million dollars this company
whatever
people don't realize the grit that goes
into this and not only is it the grit
but it's the
it's actually like from a statistics
standpoint if you like analyze this
statistically i think that
by all definitions being an entrepreneur
is
actually insane you got to be insane to
be an entrepreneur like you
you know i say this all the time if you
tell me that i'm going to stand in that
place and there's a 95
chance that lightning will strike well
why would i do that you got to be an
idiot but if i tell you to spend
millions of dollars and years of your
life building something
and 95 chance will fail why would you do
that and the answer is because you have
entrepreneurs running through your veins
you don't have a choice as an
entrepreneur and so number one i think
that the biggest mistake
that people make is to glorify what it
means to be a successful entrepreneur
and that manifests itself in so many
ways just to give one example
you know people think about oh i'm gonna
launch it and you know yeah i'm gonna
get pressed i'm gonna get funding well
where does the research come in here no
one talks about oh i did you know two
months of market research in competitive
analysis because that's not a sexy story
but you will 100 fail as an entrepreneur
if you don't know who you're up against
and to be clear i don't mean
you know doing a couple of hours of
googling to figuring out to figure out
that no one's doing the exact same thing
as you so you can go tell your investor
look no one's doing the same thing as me
what i mean is building a landscape of
50 to 100 companies
that are in your space when i say in
your space i don't mean they're building
the exact same thing as you i mean who's
targeting your target audience
i mean who's using the same value
proposition who's using your pitch even
if it's a different product you might be
using mobile they might be using web but
are they targeting the washington post
and you're targeting the washington post
are you both offering the washington
post you know more time on page for
their readers
than your direct competitors so do that
research before you spend a dime
literally on anything spend a month two
months building that landscape of 50 to
100 companies
not for an investor not for anybody for
yourself because
and be humble enough to say all right
maybe this was a mistake because look
what's going on here
and there are 35 companies that have
succeeded in my space or
alternatively there are 35 companies who
have tried and failed in my space and i
don't know why they failed
and why i'm going to succeed but all of
these things are absolutely crucial
because otherwise you're
basically shooting in the dark you don't
even know who you're up against you
don't know who's tried who's failed to
succeed
why they failed why they succeeded so
the answer is stop glorifying it it's
not as sexy as you think
and start working your butt off and
doing a lot of research knowing what
you're up against
and only then once you decide that after
seeing the entire
you know wider perspective of the market
you're still ready to move forward
then we can start talking yeah you know
i mean i i've had the privilege now of
of working with oded
harmony and j ventures for a bit over
six months
and seeing a lot of startups meeting a
lot of founders and following up on due
diligence and one of the
things that i started noticing uh pretty
quickly is that
one of the one of the big red flags that
you get is when you're asking these
founders some of the difficult questions
and their answers are too good to be
sure they're way too confident
in all the different aspects and it's as
if there's no gaps because
there's always crap somewhere and and if
they don't volunteer to to bring it up
then
then something smells and then you
you're left with a question did
are is this honest is this truthful i
much rather see a person who
acknowledges that
the downsides of what's happening than
somebody who says this is all flowers
and happiness
so he'll in order to wake up at at 4 a.m
and
and and even if you wake up at 4am and
you go to sleep
and whenever you go to sleep you still
only have so many hours in the day yet
you manage to do so much
and you're you take pride in your
productivity i know that
so teach me a little bit of productivity
and what can i do to improve my
productivity
well i i take more than pride in my
productivity it actually makes me
profoundly happy to be productive
honestly and vice versa when i'm not
productive i feel
down like i gotta do stuff i'll call it
add call whatever you want but um
yeah i love being productive that's the
truth um and i'm gonna
i guess do something a little
uncharacteristic
i hope of myself and and pat myself on
the on the shoulder here and say that
what i what i get done on an average day
i think the average person gets done in
a week you know and i'm being that's
another
i think it's probably more than that and
the reason is that i've
i've highly highly optimized my time
management
um i've created certain uh shortcuts
slash hacks into um maximizing my time
and cutting corners
where it's applicable and appropriate to
cut corners and not
this is a very important emphasis and
not where it's inappropriate about
corners so i'm not cutting corners i'm
building relationships
i'm not cutting quarters and automating
my social media so that i post one thing
that
distributes everywhere because that's
not personalizing it to a specific
audience and that's just
defeating the purpose i'm cutting
quarters where i can so for example
one of my favorite and i don't i call it
a hack just for lack of a better term
it's not a hack it's built into the
iphone
is um is communication and i i
basically set up in my settings
of the keyboard on my iphone
basically an entire dictionary and i
quite literally i mean a dictionary
full of keyboard shortcuts so when i
uh i'm writing an email you know someone
says to me for example okay let's meet
you know tomorrow morning at 9am i now
need to send them an email saying
or a message saying okay great thank you
you know if you don't mind please send
me a calendar invite so it's locked in
here's my email address and that's you
know i sent you yesterday
uh and and that's just to be you know
i'll show
maybe i'll be able to demo it for you
let's see this is my email yeah i'm
gonna show it to you
all right so if i write the words lock
it's hard to type like this can you see
myself yeah i write the word lock
lock yeah and we're lock again
and lock boom wow
right just so how many of those do you
have fills in the sentence and i've
basically i just want to show you what
that looks like
on my actual screen uh in my key in my
general settings of my iphone
on their keyboard there's a thing called
text replacements here
text replacements and these are all the
text replacements holy crap
wow so when i say to you that out of
every 20 emails that i send
i would say 19 of them or maybe 18 of
them are actual shortcuts and i didn't
actually write the email
it's not an exaggeration anybody asked
me for my bio you asked me for my bio
boom send you the bio in what how long a
second
all right it was very very impressive
someone says to me you know i want to
meet you this is this is a good one
actually
entrepreneurs write to me i don't know
50 times a day i want to meet
right okay hillary clinton we have
coffee or now a zoom
now here's my objective my objective is
on the one hand
to be a mensch and try to be nice to
them on the other hand i don't want to
be
a waste of wasting my time and you know
if this is a person that wants to meet
because
you know they want an introduction to
investors and send me an email i'll
forward to an investor and i can
introduction i need to meet you for that
and it's just a waste of my time and
your time i'm not saying i don't have
some kind of hot chocolate why waste
time
no last time we met you you explained to
me how important it is for you to know
that you're
able to provide them value and you're
aware of your shortcomings and some
there are some cases where you don't
feel like you can provide value and you
don't want you don't want to do that
then
100 i'm not going to definitely you know
that's one that's question 101 well what
do you even do i mean if you're building
you know
a an electrical engineering you know
what
what am i gonna do for you you know if
you're building um i don't know a deep
deep deck and cyber it's just not my
area right
um now if i can help fantastic i'm
always happy to help it but let's make
sure that it's relevant and so i
i i have to ask the question what is the
context of this meeting you want to meet
why do you want to meet you want to meet
because you want introduction investors
you want to meet because you want me to
write about you you want me to meet
because
let me interview you what are we meeting
about i have to ask that question in a
way that's
again not condescending but gets to the
point but it's also very not
like our world right especially here
you know having been here for about
eight months in palo alto
if i were to if somebody would ask me
hey let's meet and i would ask them hey
what are you trying
why are we meeting that's insulting how
do you how do you get around that
so i i mean i can i'll i'll read to you
literally just so you know
i showed you this the lock lock thing
yeah you show you the one i write the
word
context context and i make it with two
question marks context
ready watch this filled in that whole
entire thing just now holy i'll tell you
what it read what it says thanks for the
email just need a bit more context here
meaning some people reach out to me as a
blogger
others because of the vlog others reach
out to marketing capacity others because
they're fundraising
i just need a bit of clarification here
of the context goal of meeting
thanks and i hope it's okay to be so
direct in my experience context is
extremely important when it comes to
these things so there is no misalignment
of expectations that could get awkward
looking forward to your response now let
me be very clear
why why i ask that i'll give you i mean
it's happened to me
i don't even know how many times
happened to me last week someone made an
introduction a friend who i really
really like and respect she just
introduced me to this entrepreneur she
didn't ask me first she can give me
context first
she just her friend said i want to speak
to her yeah i know you're friends with
him can you introduce me so she need the
introduction
and so we jump on the call and again i'm
not throwing anyone under the bus it's a
great company they do great things but
what did she want from me
she's she built a developer tool and she
wants me to introduce her to developers
and tech companies
so number one i'm like and i said the
center i don't mean that i didn't say it
in this way but hello i'm not your sales
team number one like
go buy your sales person number two my
relationships and organizations are not
with this with the developer right
i'm on the marketing front like people
say all the time hey you work with
google can you get me a job there i'm
like come on dude really
you know so like it's and then i'll
email your dad by the way
but but uh but the point is like
you know i listen i try to be nice to
people i try to be respectful but i need
i need to you know see if it's relevant
so i send that email and that saved me
hundreds and hundreds of hours of
meetings that were just unnecessary
um but the bottom line is in terms of
the productivity hack you know these
shortcuts are super super helpful
even your email address how many times a
day do you write your email address so
instead of writing out my email address
i write four letters and it fills it in
that's right
like my phone number my home address
anything that i write more than once
i set up a shortcut i'm driving and
someone texts me that i
that i don't want to ignore but i don't
want to text them i'm driving so i write
the word
t-r-i-i driving but d-r-i-i that's it
and it writes i'm driving i'll talk to
you later so they get a response they're
happy and i
there you go just for example the point
is i have 100 you saw i have hundreds of
them
and i use them all the time like for
just for everything i mean
getting people jobs i set up a folder in
my google drive full of cds instead of
going to my google drive and copying the
link and then pasting it every time
i set up a shortcut saying you're
looking for a tech person you'll be a
marketing person
i write the word marketing cv it fills
in here's a link to marketing tvs
i saved myself countless counselors you
know hello somebody told me somebody
told me when i was younger
if you want something to get done give
it to the busiest person in the room
and i think i mean you're you're just an
example of that you
it's people who are who get excited
about about getting stuff done and
they'll find a way to get everything
done and do it in a very very good way
and i i i feel i i feel very i it really
speaks to me what you're saying
when i have a slow day when nothing too
much is happening it's very hard for me
to get anything done but when i have a
day of 100 things
the 100th and first thing that i have to
do easy
it's somehow it ends up in the calendar
and it gets done immediately
you get exposed to so many industries
what's your favorite
where which what do you really get
excited about and
if you had to choose where you would
work in which industry which one would
it be
um well i guess i can answer that
question in two ways
let's see you can answer that question
as a consumer myself and that's an
important point by the way you know
oftentimes people
you know they tell her they're messaging
for like cios or ctos they forget that
that cio or cto
goes home at six o'clock and becomes a
consumer so everyone's consumers
so i can answer that question from a
consumer perspective and then maybe from
a
um let's call it market analyst or
blogger
journalist perspective from a consumer
perspective the tech that most excites
me by far
is drones i mean if you think about i'm
saying like if you
if you want to know how far we've come
technologically honestly there's nothing
better that to depict that and
illustrate that than a drone
i mean i'm talking about i have upstairs
you know the yeah mavic um
you know the new uh the new mavic mini
this thing is this big
it's this big it has i don't know how
many cameras on it it has
endless sensors built in you have 20 gps
satellites connected to this thing at
any given point it flies
miles away it takes you know basically
professional level video
this big it's it's wild i mean it's just
wild in there and there are the amount
of companies in the space
uh edgy bees and all these companies
building technology for drones
it's it's truly an unbelievable space
and i know personally i have a
collection of drones here right next to
me
um and i love them and they're
unbelievable and truly like
it's hard to believe that that's as far
as i'm concerned
the two technologies that i think really
make me feel like i'm in the future
are drones and autonomous cars right my
volvo's semi-autonomous i drive to tel
aviv without touching the steering wheel
or the
gas it's crazy yeah parking is it's wild
i feel like i'm
in a science fiction movie uh so i think
that that that's from a uh
from a consumer perspective i'd say
drones and autonomous cars you know
autonomous drivings
are just blow my mind um from the
from a market perspective the things
that interest me most i think
um or the space that interests me most
um
is the the whole human computer
interaction so how do humans could
interact with computers right in other
words
once upon a time we obviously had the
clicker i mean the mouse was
a mouse right this thing i mean if you
think about what's happening here i
haven't seen this since it's like second
grade
i i'm just saying like think about what
you're doing really
really right so we have that and then
comes you know
this which is is not fundamentally
better
in my humble opinion i still think the
fact that people walking around like
this in 2020 is absurd
um i don't know you know
i'm not a prophet but i but this is
going to change
right and uh in general i think the way
we interact
uh with virtual content you know ar vr
mr right i mean
leaving outside the whole uh monster
valuation whether that was justified or
not
i don't know if you had a chance to demo
magic leap but it blew my mind magically
literally from a technological
perspective it blew my mind i'm
interacting physically with something
virtual
i'm hitting down dominoes that aren't
really there
makes no sense and really bends your
mind so the whole how we're going to
interact with computers
uh in the future whether it's holograms
glasses ar
we're surely not going to be wearing
virtual headsets like in today's form
uh form factor but that that that
intrigues me because that has to change
we're all becoming increasingly
dependent on our devices and
we are looking at acting like zombies
when we sit there like this
so that's gonna change and i'm curious
to see where it goes but
from a market perspective all you know
all the hyper of
vr and all the things that i'm sure
you've experienced i've had the chance
to demo some technology that
it's it literally like i there's a
company in israel called odyssey
they call it hyper reality where they
put me in a room half the size of this
room tiny little room and i know in my
brain that i'm in a room so
like how does your brain trick you you
know you're in a room they put like a
knapsack on me
and headset on me and i'm in a virtual
reality scene
and what they do is if i approach a fire
in the scene they put a
like a heater in the room so when i poke
the fire i feel hot right and so it
it uses all your senses and i'm telling
you at one point in the scene i'm
standing on a
on a shaky bridge and i swear to you i
was paralyzed i couldn't move i was
terrified
and and in my brain i knew i'm in a room
i knew like you're in a freaking room
dude
doesn't help my brain doesn't understand
what it's seeing it's
digest it's wild um you know i don't
know how to apply that technology that's
a discussion whether there is an
application for this the whole arm rvr
thing
but from a technological perspective it
blows my mind and i think
um you know there have been many
attempts obviously at interact with our
devices differently google glass and all
those guys but i don't think anyone's
really cracked it
whoever does has a big paycheck ahead of
them unbelievable
hello one of the things that i've been
most curious about um
is a religion and and how religion plays
in tech and you know every week you
you say you submit a post signing off
for 25 plus
hours of family or whatever how do you
deal with that dissonance that
you're blogging all day long you're
constantly
active on social media and on the
whatever devices and then comes the
weekend and you
take the time off and you disconnect how
does it work
well i'm gonna i'm gonna push back on
your premise why
why is there a dissonance i don't i'm
not understanding i i think they
actually go like a glove on a hand
perfect you compliments it perfectly
tell me i'm in hyper
mode i'm working 18 hours a day
and shabbat i'm offline i disconnect and
i
you know i focus internally um
whether it's prayer whether it's being
with friends and family it actually in
my opinion if i did not have shabbat
i'll be honest with you i'm not judging
anyone but if i did not have a sharp i'd
lose my mind
i could be in hyper mode 24 7 35 days a
year
and i love it so you know number one you
know people ask me this question
in a broader way if whether or not my
coupon that i wear on my head or other
things
you know affect my career and i'll be
honest like over the years and i just
got it i just got a uh
slack message half an hour ago from the
inc uh magazine team that i was invited
to a virtual event
today at seven uh uh sorry it's 12
00 p.m uh eastern standard time which is
shabbat in israel which i don't use
electronics so i can't join it
so from a logistical technical
perspective i've lost out quote on quote
on opportunities over the years
summits and events i was invited to even
by google that i couldn't do because on
friday and shabbat
this expert summit in california once a
year that i couldn't come to the last
two years
so from that perspective i've quote
unquote lost out
but from a professional perspective
career-wise not only have i not lost out
but i believe
it's become part of my brand and people
a come to expect it and be
respected of course i try to
take the lessons the torah lessons and i
teach my kids and apply them to business
every week and now i'm writing a book
about that
um and so i think it's become
i don't think it's giving me a challenge
i need to actually become part of my
i'm not going to say success because i'm
not a success story part of my brain
it's part of my thing
yeah i i started doing something called
digital sabbath
um from with inspiration from my friend
group bent he
he's at the stanford business school now
and he does digital sabbath for every
saturday he
logs off he's not religious or anything
but he says this is a time for him to
reflect
and take a mental break and and allow
his brain to focus on things that in the
day-to-day
there is just no space to and heim tesla
from our crowd also
uh he he he told me that i should try it
out and i did and i loved it
and i've been doing it a few times and
but you know it's hard sometimes that
you constantly have this expectation
from yourself and others to be
constantly connected
and all of a sudden feeling that i know
that i have 10 messages now
and i don't know what opportunities are
on my phone and i'm not going to touch
it
and unless it's ingrained in you it's
difficult
yeah but it sounds but but it's
definitely something that i've been
trying to do
hello you have to go to meet your 50
other people of the day but before that
i need three words that describe you
oh three words how about three letters
let's do it
uh the three words that describe me i
mean that i describe myself are that i
hope others describe me they have to be
clarify the question you choose that i
hope
you know that one day people will
describe me with these three words i'll
say
hopefully uh hopefully generous
um um i would say
passionate for sure um and
facilitator i would hope that that would
be the word to describe what i do
i try to facilitate the success of
others and give others a stage
when when too many people are focused on
promoting themselves i
i realize that actually promoting others
is the best business model because you
end up sharing that stage with them
so uh i hope facilitator and i'll add a
fourth one last time we met
in serona you told me stay a man should
be i mentioned stay a mensch
so i'm gonna add that a fourth one for
you as a mensch hello thank you so much
if i had said that i wouldn't be a
mensch
if i said that about myself there you go
hello thank you so much
thank you
you